furniture here some items there alhadi
ali is trying to collect what he can
from his home it was damaged and left
submerged by heavy rains and torrential
floods in al-managal in sudan's jazeera
state
we now don't have any food or water the
floods came in the middle of the night
while i was working on a night shift to
be able to provide food for my family
similar damage and destruction can be
seen in houses around the village more
than 700 homes were destroyed in over 50
villages in al-managal the district has
been declared a disaster zone
ibrahim yusuf's family was one of more
than 3 000 affected by the floods in the
region
the water came in tore down the front
walls they then entered the rooms and we
moved away as they started collapsing
around us all these houses have
collapsed
almanagel is now largely submerged homes
are not the only places affected
farmlands have also been devastated by
floods threatening the harvest season
around november
already nearly a third of sudan's 43
million people are short of food and
prices have increased in the past month
government officials say the scale of
damage in al-managal is unprecedented
we were expecting the damage to be less
so we were surprised by the amount of
destruction
the flood season usually causes damage
but what we have seen this year is
beyond the state's ability to respond
many people are now waiting for help but
with more torrential rains forecast and
floods expected they're worried it may
come too late hiber morgan al jazeera